d'après les chercheurs en cosmologie
nous serions actuellement dans un
univers qui non seulement est en
expansion mais en plus en expansion
accélérée et ce phénomène serait
peut-être dû à une mystérieuse substance
qu'on appelle l'énergie sombre et qui
conduirait à terme à un grand
déchirement de tout ce qui peuple
l'univers les galaxies les étoiles les
planètes et nous avec plutôt intrigant
non alors dans cette vidéo et la
suivante on va essayer de comprendre ce
que signifie cette histoire expansion
accélérée de l'univers comment elle a
été découverte de façon plutôt
inattendue il y a environ 25 ans et on
se demandera si on a vraiment besoin
d'énergie sombre pour
l'expliquer pour commencer je vais
rappeler ce qu'est l'expansion de
l'Univers tout court et comment on la
concevait avant qu'on ne découvre ce
phénomène d'accélération je vais répéter
quelques points que j'ai déjà abordé
dans d'autres vidéos mais je vais être
un peu plus précis d'habitude pour bien
pouvoir comprendre ensuite cette
histoire d'accélération le phénomène
d'expansion l'univers a été découvert en
1929 par l'astronome américain Edwin
Hubble à l'époque il observait
différentes galaxies et s'efforçait de
mesurer leur distance et leur vitesse
par rapport à nous il avait alors
constaté une chose étonnante toutes les
galaxies qui nous entourent semblent
s'éloigner de nous et ce d'autant plus
vite qu'elles sont lointaines Hubble
avait publié à l'époque ce diagramme on
y voit la distance en abscisse et la
vitesse d'éloignement en ordonnée et
chaque point représente une galaxie et
il semble y avoir une relation de
proportionnalité entre les deux plus une
galaxie est lointaine plus elle
s'éloigne vite de nous ce diagramme
était assez surprenant on aurait pu
s'attendre à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
lien particulier entre la distance et la
vitesse d'une galaxie mais non non
seulement toutes les galaxies
s'éloignent mais en plus a une vitesse
proportionnelle à leur distance avant de
creuser l'interprétation de ce genre de
diagramme il est vrai vraiment important
de comprendre à partir de quel type de
mesure il a été réalisé commençons par
la distance de façon générale quand on
observe un objet astrophysique et qu'on
mesure par exemple sa luminosité ça ne
nous renseigne pas forcément très bien
sur sa distance par rapport à nous par
exemple si la luminosité d'une étoile
dans le ciel est faible est-ce que c'est
parce qu'elle se trouve loin de nous ou
bien qu'elle se trouve proche de nous
mais qu'il s'agit d'une étoile qui n'est
pas très puissante pas évident de
trancher juste avec ça pour estimer la
distance de façon fiable il faut des
objets dont on connaît déjà par avance
la puissance ce qu'on appelle leur
luminosité intrinsèque si vous la
connaissez alors en mesurant la
luminosité apparente vous pouvez en
déduire leur distance des objets de ce
genre dont on connaît par avance la
puissance lumineuse intrinsèque on
appelle ça des chandelles standard à
l'époque Hubble avait utilisé comme
chandell standard certaines étoiles
variables dont on connaît la puissance
intrinsèque grâce à leur période de de
variation il avait ainsi pu estimer la
distance de quelques galaxies qui
contenaient ce type d'étoile ensuite
pour mesurer la vitesse ble avait
utilisé un phénomène découvert quelques
années plus tôt le décalage vers le
rouge des longueurs d'ondes en effet
quand on mesure le spectre lumineux des
étoiles d'une galaxie lointaine on
trouve toujours que les longueurs
d'ondes des rais d'émission ou
d'absorption sont plus grandes que
celles qu'on mesure sur terre pour des
longueurs d'ondes de la lumière visible
elles apparaissent décalées vers le
rouge
à l'époque on interprétait ça comme un
effet doppire l'effet doplire c'est lui
qui fait qu'une sirène de Pompi semble
plus grave quand le camion s'éloigne de
nous la longueur d'onde du son se trouve
étirée du fait du déplacement de la
source et pour les galaxies on a
simplement penser à la même chose avec
la lumière au lieu du son le décalage
vers le rouge des galaxies a donc été
initialement interprété comme la
conséquence de leur vitesse
d'éloignement et c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut quantifier pour ça on on
mesure le pourcentage d'augmentation des
longueurs d'onde si par exemple toutes
les longueurs d'onde sont 4 % plus élevé
que prévu on dit que le décalage est de
0,04 on le note généralement Z et on
utilise parfois le terme anglo-axon de
redshift et on peut l'interpréter en
disant que la source lumineuse se
déplaçait à ce pourcentage de la vitesse
de la lumière sur mon exemple he 4 % de
300000 ça fait 12000 km/se donc de façon
générale selon cette interprétation
mesurer le décalage longueurs d'onde
donne une idée de la vitesse de la
galaxie par rapport à nous ce qu'on
verra par la suite c'est que cette
interprétation effet d'opleur qu'on
avait à l'époque elle est en fait un peu
incorrecte pour la suite il faut donc se
souvenir que ce qu'on mesure vraiment ça
n'est pas directement la vitesse mais
c'est ce red shift noté Z et donc en
toute rigueur on devrait plutôt graduer
le diagramme en utilisant Z plutôt que
la vitesse qu'on en a déduite depuis les
travaux de Hubble on a pu mesurer
beaucoup plus de galaxies de plus en
plus lointaines et ainsi confirmer cette
relation de proportionnalité entre
distance et vitesse ou plutôt entre la
distance et le Z on voit ici des mesures
bien plus récentes et les observations
initiales de Hubble correspondrai
seulement à la toute petite zone dans le
coin en bas à gauche mais la relation de
proportionnalité semble bien solide et
la constante de proportionnalité c'est
ce qu'on appelle la constante de Hubble
bien c'est donc cette observation de
l'éloignement des galaxies les unes par
rapport aux autres qui est à la base de
l'idée d'expansion l'univers les mesures
de et de ses successeurs semble nous
dire qu'actuellement l'univers est
effectivement en expansion et à un
rythme que l'on peut mesurer une
question naturelle qu'on peut se poser
c'est est-ce que cette expansion s'est
toujours faite au même rythme est-ce que
dans le passé elle était plus faible
plus forte ce que vous savez sans doute
c'est qu'en astrophysique plus on
regarde loin plus on regarde dans le
passé de l'univers puisque la lumière a
mis un certain temps à nous parvenir
mais sur le diagramme de Hubble que je
vous ai montré on a pas été assez loin
pour remonter suffisamment dans le passé
on voit qu'on a des galaxies situées à
les maximum à environ un milliard
d'années lumière leur lumière a donc été
émise il y a 1 milliard d'années mais
l'univers est âgé de 13,8 milliards
d'années donc il y a 1 milliard d'années
il n'était pas si différent
d'aujourd'hui ce diagramme de Hubble
nous renseigne surtout sur le présent
pas tellement sur le passé pour
reconstituer l'état de l'univers il y a
plusieurs milliards d'années on ne se
base donc pas sur ceses ure directement
mais on utilise des modèles théoriques
de l'expansion l'univers et il se trouve
que ceux-ci ont été élaborés à peu près
à la même époque que les découvertes de
Hubble dans les années 1920 deux
scientifiques le Russe Alexander
Friedman et le Belge George lemettre
mettent au point indépendamment les
premiers modèles cosmologiques en se
basant sur les équations de la
relativité générale établie une dizaine
d'années plus tôt par Einstein et très
vite même avant la découverte de Hubble
le maître réalise que ces équations
impliquent que l'univers puisse être en
expansion et il devine que cela doit se
manifester par une relation entre la
vitesse et la distance des galaxies
Hubble ne connaissait pas à l'époque les
travaux de le mètre mais on peut dire
que ce dernier l'avait en quelque sorte
devancé par ses calculs et d'ailleurs on
appelle maintenant cette relation de
proportionnalité la loi de Hubble le
maître pour établir leur modèle
cosmologique Friedman et le maître
raisonnent sur une quantité très
importante qu'on appelle le facteur
d'échelle de l'univers et qu'on note
petite a il s'agit d'un nombre qui
évolue au cours du temps et qui
représente l'échelle des distances dans
l'univers rapporté aux distances
actuelles alors qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire actuellement par définition le
facteur d'échelle vaut 1 imaginons deux
galaxies situées aujourd'hui à une
distance de 200 millions d'années
lumières dans le passé le facteur
d'échelle était plus faible disons 0,5
elle n'était alors distante que de la
moitié 100 millions d'années lumièr
et si un jour le facteur d'échelle vaut
disons 2,5 elles seront 2,5 fois plus
éloignées qu'aujourd'hui à 500 millions
d'années lumière le facteur d'échelle
est donc la quantité importante qui
décrit l'évolution de la géométrie de
l'univers et nous renseigne sur les
distances entre les galaxies et ce que
permett de faire les équations de
Friedman et le maître c'est de
quantifier cette évolution au cours du
temps à la fois pour reconstituer le
passé mais aussi pour extrapoler vers le
futur ce qu'on veut c'est donc tracer
cette courbe l'évolution du facteur
d'échelle petit a au cours du temps on
l'a dit aujourd'hui il vaut 1 par
définition et par convention aujourd'hui
c'est le temps zéro donc on est à ce
point-là mais on connaît aussi la pente
de l'évolution du facteur d'échelle
puisque la constante de Hubble quantifie
l'expansion actuelle de l'univers donc
on connaît aussi ça mais juste avec ce
petit morceau de courbe on sait pas ce
qu' s'est passé avant ou se passera
après mais les équation de Freedman le
mettre permettent justement de le
reconstituer et de proposer des
scénarios qui respectent les les
équations de la relativité générale en
voici quelques-uns représentés et ils
ont des allures différentes on voit que
dans certains cas le facteur d'échelle
augmentera passera par un maximum et
diminuera ensuite jusqu'à éro ça
signifie que l'univers finira par se
recontracter et terminera dans ce qu'on
appelle parfois un Big Crunch et puis
pour d'autres scénarios l'expansion
continuera à l'infini l'univers se
déluera et se refroidira indéfiniment
dans ce qu'on appelle parfois un big
chill ce qui dit différencie ces
différents scénarios c'est la densité de
matière et d'énergie présente dans
l'univers si elle est suffisamment
élevée on aura un scénario ambic crrunch
et si elle est trop faible une expansion
éternelle en big chill ça fait un
éventail de possibilités mais une chose
qu'on peut toutefois remarquer sur ces
courbes c'est que l'expansion est
toujours en décélération même dans le
cas d'une expansion qui sera éternelle
la pente de la courbe s'aplatit de plus
en plus au cours du temps donc même si
elle continue indéfiniment l'expansion
est toujours de moins en moins forte
elle n'accélère jamais pour mieux
comprendre ces différents scénarios on
peut prendre une analogie imaginez que
vous soyez au 10e étage d'un immeuble à
regarder par la fenêtre et que vous
voyez passer devant vos yeux un
projectile en train de partir
verticalement vers le ciel supposons que
vous puissiez mesurer la vitesse du
projectile quand il passe devant vos
yeux ce projectile peut avoir deux
destin soit il va monter jusqu'à une
certaine hauteur puis redescendre vers
le sol soit il va continuer s'arracher
de l'attraction terrestre et partir dans
l'espace et cela dépend de sa vitesse
actuelle et la force de gravité et dans
les deux cas le projectile est forcément
en décélération sa vitesse d'éloignement
ne peut que décroître et si vous voulez
estimer sa décélération vous ne pouvez
pas mesurer juste la vitesse quand il
passe devant vous il vous faut un point
de comparaison par exemple la mesurer
aussi un petit peu plus bas sur la
trajectoire et puis faire la différence
et bien pour l'univers c'est pareil si
on veut reconstituer comment il a évolué
on on ne peut pas se contenter de
regarder le présent car toutes les
courbes sont similaires dans les
différents modèles il faut aussi être
capable de regarder suffisamment dans le
passé pour voir les différences et
regarder dans le passé on l'a dit ça se
fait en regardant plus loin tout à
l'heure quand je vous ai montré le
diagramme de Hubble je vous ai dit qu'à
peu de chos près il ne nous renseignait
que sur l'état actuel de l'univers car
il ne regardait pas d'objets
astrophysiques suffisamment lointain
pour espérer distinguer quelque chose il
faut prolonger ce diagramme ce que l'on
sait c'est que cette loi de
proportionnalité de Hubble qui relie la
distance et le décalage Z n'est
qu'approximative si on va à des valeurs
de Z suffisamment grandes on commencera
à avoir des déviations qui nous
permettront de discriminer les
différents scénarios tout à l'heure vous
vous en souvenez j'ai parlé de vitesse
d'effet doppleur et je vous ai dit qu'il
fallait prendre cette interprétation
avec des pincettes car ça n'est pas ça
la véritable explication physique du
décalage des longueurs d'onde et si on
essaie d'aller justement regarder des
galaxies avec des décalages élevés cette
subtilité devient importante dans
l'effet doppleur tel qu'il se produit
pour le son on a une onde qui se déplace
dans un certain milieu matériel l'air et
une source qui se déplace par rapport à
ce milieu on peut voir la longueur
d'onde du son comme la distance qui
sépare deux crêtes du signal sonore or
ces deux crêtes sont émises par la
source à un certain intervalle de temps
donc si la source se déplace légèrement
entre l'émission des deux crêtes la
distance entre les deux va se trouver
allongée par rapport à la normale donc
la longueur d'onde sera plus importante
et le son plus grave que prévu et le
pourcentage d'allongement sera le ratio
de la vitesse de la source divisée par
la vitesse du son avec l'expansion de
l'Univers c'est différent l'origine du
décalage vers le rouge c'est que les
longueurs d'ondes de la lumière la
distance entre les deux crêtes
augmentent au cours du temps du fait de
l'expansion de l'Univers la longueur
d'onde se dilate ça n'est donc pas un
phénomène de décalage qui se produit au
moment de l'émission de la lumière he
comme pour l'effet dopleur mais c'est un
effet qui s'accumule progressivement
pendant tout le trajet de long lumineuse
jusqu'à sa destination pour connaître
l'intensité du décalage c'est simple on
applique le principe d'expansion des
distances c'est-à-dire qu'on regarde
comment a changé le facteur d'échelle le
temps du trajet de la lumière imaginons
une galaxie qu'on observe et dont la
lumière est été émise quand le facteur
d'échelle de l'univers n'était que de
2/3 aujourd'hui le facteur d'échelle est
1 donc il a augmenté de 50 %. les
longueurs d'onde seront donc toutes
augmenté de 50 %. c'est ce qu'on appelle
un Z de
0,5 maintenant imaginez une lumière que
l'on capte aujourd'hui mais qui a été
émise quand le facteur d'échelle était
1/3 vu d'aujourd'hui cela fera un
triplement de la longueur d'onde une
augmentation de 200 %. donc ça
correspond à un Z = à 2 et si on remonte
encore plus loin dans le passé de
l'univers Z peut être encore plus grand
je vous rappelle que dans une
interprétation Doppler le le décalage Z
c'est la vitesse de la source par
rapport à la vitesse de la lumière Z = 2
ça voudrait dire une vitesse
d'éloignement qui serait le double de la
vitesse de la lumière c'est un peu
compliqué à justifier avec la bonne
interprétation du décalage vers le rouge
vous voyez que mesurer Z à partir d'un
spectre lumineux cela permet de
connaître non pas une vitesse mais
directement la valeur du facteur
d'échelle au moment de l'émission de la
lumière ça nous renseigne donc sur
l'état de l'univers à ce moment-là et
grâce à ça on regardant suffisamment
loin on doit pouvoir faire le tri entre
les différents modèles
cosmologiques ici je vous ai remis en
différentes couleurs à gauche les
évolutions possibles du facteur
d'échelle en fonction des différents
modèles les courbes les plus foncées
correspondant à des densités moyennes de
l'univers plus élevé et à droite je vous
ai mis ce qu'on devrait observer pour le
diagramme de Hubble selon ces différents
modèles si on arrive à observer des
objets astrophysiques suffisamment
lointains avec des Z élevés on peut voir
ça comme un diagramme de de Hubble
étendu vous voyez qu'à faible distance
et faible red shift les courbes sont
toutes confondues et les mesures qu'on
avait jusqu'ici pour le diagramme de
Hubble était dans ce coin-là et si on va
mesurer à des distances importantes et
des Z suffisamment élevés proche de 1
par exemple on peut commencer à savoir
dans quel scénario on se trouve ici plus
la courbe est haute plus la décélération
de l'univers est forte donc plus il y a
de matière dans l'univers inversement
plus la courbe est basse plus la
décélération est faible et moins il a de
matière la courbe en pointill et noir
c'est le cas limite où il n'y aurait
aucune matière dans l'univers et donc
aucune décélération voilà on a donc un
moyen expérimental de savoir dans lequel
des scénarios on se trouve en complétant
le diagramme de Hubble par des
observations suffisamment lointaines bon
ben il y a plus
qu'à justement dans les années 90 deux
équipes de recherche se sont formées
avec l'ambition d'étendre le diagramme
de Hubble pour pouvoir ir lever cette
incertitude la collaboration iy et la
collaboration SNC pour supernova
cosmology project ces deux équipe qui
était de fait en concurrence avait pour
objectif initial de mesurer la
décélération de l'univers en utilisant
des supernova lointaines les supernova
et notamment celles qu'on appelle de
type 1a sont en effet des explosions
d'étoiles qui constituent des chandelles
standard car elles se produisent
toujours selon le même scénario voyez
ici une vue d'artiste du fait om quand
une étoile naine blanche se trouve
proche d'une autre étoile dont elle peut
chippper la matière elle la dépouille
progressivement et grossit mais quand la
naine blanche atteint une masse assez
précise environ 1,4 fois la masse du
Soleil une explosion thermonucléaire
ultra violente se déclenche la
luminosité intrinsèque de l'explosion
est absolument colossale et évolue selon
une courbe bien connue et calibrée on
peut donc à partir de sa luminosité
apparente estimer la de la supernova et
en bonus comme l'explosion est
incroyablement puissante ces supernova
peuvent être observés dans des galaxies
très distantes plusieurs milliards
d'années lumière la difficulté c'est que
ces événements sont très transitoires et
très rares ils ne se produit que
quelques supernova par millénaire dans
une galaxie typique nos deux équipes de
chercheurs ont donc mis en place des
méthodes de surveillance de large
portion du ciel permettant de repérer le
maximum de supernova sans savoir à
l'avance où elles allaient se produire
en 1998 les deux collaborations ont
quasi simultanément annoncé leur
résultat et là ce fut une surprise alors
qu'elles étaient parties au départ pour
mesurer la décélération de l'expansion
l'univers les deux ont indépendamment
découvert que l'expansion était en fait
en accélération souvenez-vous de ce
diagramme à droite qui représente la
distance en fonction du décalage Z dans
les modèles de Friedman le mare et qui
diffèrent par la densité de matière
densité sité faible pour les courbes les
plus basses densité élevée pour celle
au-dessus et en pointiller la limite
extrême d'une densité nulle et bien les
observations de supernova ont montré
qu'ell se situaient par ici dans une
zone impossible à expliquer avec un
univers en décélération et donc aucun
des modèles d'évolution du facteur
d'échelle représenté à gauche ne peut
être correct il faut trouver autre chose
qui soit compatible avec ces nouvelles
données d'expansion accélérée pour cette
découverte inattendue les deux équipes
ont reçu en 2011 le prix Nobel de
physique alors je dis les équipes hein
en fait le prix Nobel de physique est
toujours décerné à des personnes et
jamais plus que trois donc ce sont les
leaders des collaborations qui l'ont eu
mais évidemment ça récompense le travail
des équipes entières bien sûr cette
découverte a renvoyé les théoriciens à
leur calcul pour essayer de comprendre
comment l'univers pouvait être en
expansion accélérée alors qu'on
envisageait plutôt jusqu'ici des modèles
en décélération bon alors j'exagère un
peu en le présentant comme ça en
pratique on n'a pas eu trop de mal à
proposer de nouveaux modèles qui collent
car ces phénomènes d'expansion accéléré
avaient déjà été envisagés et étudiés
sur le plan théorique il en existe
plusieurs variantes mais toutes
prédisent une évolution du facteur
d'échelle de ce genre une expansion
éternelle et de plus en plus forte qui
finira par tout déchirer avec elle ce
qu'on appelle parfois un big RIP sur le
plan théorique il existe plusieurs
façons d'obtenir une telle évolution et
dans la prochaine vidéo on verra plus
précis ces différentes hypothèses
susceptibles d'expliquer cette expansion
accélérée on essaiera notamment de
comprendre ce qu'est cette mystérieuse
énergie sombre qui composerait
soi-disant 70 % de l'univers et on se
demandera si on en a vraiment besoin
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui merci
d'avoir suivi la vidéo abonnez-vous pour
augmenter vos chances de voir passer les
prochaines vidéos rejoignez le serveur
discord de science étonnante pour
prolonger la discussion je vous mets le
lien en description et puis moi je vous
dis à très vite pour la prochaine vidéo
à bien
[Musique]
tout